l'Insee était ta meilleure amie
tu es tout le temps ensemble c'était
vraiment
pas beaucoup de temps
et malheureusement vous étiez aussi vous
aussi victime de harcèlement ça vous
touchez toutes les deux
aujourd'hui quand tu as vu le drame qui
s'est passé pour le lycée forcément
je t'ai dit c'est je pense que tu as eu
la plus grande peine de toute ta vie
et en plus derrière
ça continue pour toi
mais Séverine
mais quand on est une maman qu'on sait
qu'il y a la meilleure amie de sa fille
qui s'est donné la mort parce qu'elle
faisait harceler et que sa fille non
seulement elle va vivre ce drame de la
mort de sa meilleure amie mais en plus
derrière elle continue à se faire
harceler par les mêmes personnes je vous
dis on a envie de se dire qu'est-ce que
je peux faire je vis dans quel monde
qu'est-ce que vers Kim vers qui je vais
me tourner vous avez fait quoi vous
faites quoi aujourd'hui
Séverine on lâchera pas cette histoire
parce qu'on pense à l'INSEE moi j'ai vu
on les parents de l'inseia ils m'ont
demandé un truc qui m'ont dit Cyril ne
nous lâche pas parce que tout le monde
nous a lâché et on vous lâchera pas et
je vous dis cette histoire il va falloir
que ça bouge parce que le proviseur qui
répond même pas et qui demande je vous
le dis parce que je vais vous dire ce
qu'il a fait le proviseur une fois qu'il
y a une RAM il a demandé à être muté
voilà je vous le dis on va pas les
lâcher sur cette histoire Séverine c'est
vrai ou pas
se barrer il va dire bah non ça y est et
voilà non mais je vous dis mais je vous
dis ici non mais c'est le monde de la
magouille je vous jure c'est un truc de
fou c'est vrai c'est moi qui vous
remercie d'être là
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous avez
fait vous avez vous avez contacté le
proviseur vous aussi pour dire que
Maylis ça se faisait harceler
et à chaque fois il nous répétait que il
avait pas le temps de nous recevoir même
après le drame après le drame
c'est les personnes qui nous ont
contactés mais en fait c'est pas pour
l'Insee c'est pour Maylis pour qu'elle
va voir un psy d'accord donc c'est elle
le problème voilà c'était il fallait
qu'elle va avoir un psy qu'elle va avoir
des médecins non mais moi je vous dis je
pète un câble de ce que vous me
dites-moi c'est vrai mais qui vous a
contacté des personnes de
l'établissement la principale adjointe
oui la principale donc vous appelle il
vous dit votre fille se faire soigner
mais c'est elle qui va aller voir un
petit c'est ça elle vous a parlé de
harcèlement
non en fait elle nous a dit que il
fallait que Maëlys allait voir un psy
pour suite au choc qu'elle a subi par
rapport à la perte de sa meilleure amie
c'est ça aussi oui mais Maylis nous a
dit que
elle veut pas
ils t'ont pas été sa meilleure amie donc
pourquoi maintenant ils vont s'acharner
sur elle à nous appeler et il vous
appelle énormément ah oui pratiquement
tous les jours pour vous dire quoi
qui est un ouvrage
ils appellent pas par contre les parents
l'Insee
donc il vous appelle vous parce que il
pense qu'il y a une chose c'est avoir ne
pas avoir d'autres problèmes en fait
c'est ça on est on est d'accord on va
pas se raconter l'histoire c'est ça
donc tu subis du harcèlement maïs il
faut qu'on aujourd'hui il faut qu'on
avance sur cette affaire il faut que ça
bouge parce que c'est inadmissible moi
je peux pas voir Maylis dans un tel état
je la vois depuis tout à l'heure et elle
a vécu un drame elle continue à vivre un
drame quotidien entre en se faisant
harceler c'est quel genre de harcèlement
c'est le harcèlement
les insultes les insultes les critiques
à l'école tout le temps à l'école que ça
soit sur les réseaux sociaux les réseaux
toujours voilà même en dehors de l'école
d'accord vous étiez au courant de
qu'est-ce faisait qu'elle se faisait
harceler avant avant le drame de l'Insee
elle vous en a parlé aussi donc d'accord
elle vous a dit maman ça va pas à
l'école voilà il y a c'est quoi c'est
toujours le même groupe de filles oui
toujours les mêmes
et elle elles sont toujours à l'école
tranquille
elles viennent jamais donc
[Musique]
c'est fou alors aujourd'hui
maïs vous vous soutenez toutes les deux
vous disiez quoi
on serait la lune pour l'autre
et que
c'est dur
tu chacune allait être là pour
l'autre et que même si on se faisait
insulté etc on a les réussir ensemble à
combattre ça à passer à passer autre au
dessus de ça
un moment ça allait trop loin qu'elle
allait les craquer ou pas du tout
[Musique]
elle le montrait mais elle le disait pas
pris comment chez ma mère qui me l'a dit
téléphoner au soir et a voulu que c'est
moi qui l'annonce à Maëlys
comment tu te sens depuis le départ de
l'Insee
en colère
triste perdu
mais surtout en colère
tu arrives à retourner à l'école quand
même et à voir ces personnes qui sont
responsables de la disparition de
l'Insee t'arrives à les revoir peut-être
tu leur dis quelque chose tu l'auras
qu'est-ce que tu leur a dit
j'ai rien dit du tout je préfère pas
parler
je préfère que
la justice face en sorte qu'elle soit
vengée
mais sont toujours là sont toujours à la
sortie là non là en ce moment non en ce
moment il y en a une toujours une pierre
soleil
et dans l'école même et dans l'école
elle continue à te péter non parce que
tu reçois encore des insultes et menaces
regardez exemple et en fait sa pote là à
l'INSEE elle est pas prête je dis cette
[__] elle va rejoindre sa meilleure amie
en décompte ou pas
bon des comptes ou pas
quand tu lis ça Maylis
c'est horrible
on peut voir que le compte s'appelle
l'Insee est enfin morte vous vous rendez
compte
et les réseaux sociaux ils te ils te
mettent il t'arrête parce que tu dis
j'ai pas envie de me faire vacciner non
mais voilà les gars tu dis j'ai pas
envie de me faire vacciner tu es radier
des réseaux il y a un compte qui
s'appelle l'Insee est enfin morte avec
elle va rejoindre sa meilleure amie et
ça passe crème non mais quand je vous
dis qu'on marche sur la tête donc
aujourd'hui c'est incroyable excusez-moi
mais c'est incroyable
vous le montrer ça au proviseur
non
je peux pas je peux pas aller là pour
vous dire c'est pas lui mais même bah
oui mais vous le
approvision
allez voir ce qui se passe plutôt au
lieu de m'appeler pour que ma fille
aille voir un psy faites plutôt le
ménage chez vous oui
maintenant on a pris un avocat d'accord
qui est maître de Buisson donc l'avocat
qui défend aussi la famille de l'INSEE
et on compte énormément sur lui quoi
pour que
le truc qu'on a tous envie de savoir
c'est toujours t'y retourner combien de
temps après au collège après le drame
aujourd'hui c'était ton retour
comment s'est passé plutôt bien les gens
t'ont dit quoi les camarades ils sont
venus vers toi
et tout le monde était bienveillant avec
moi
mais ça s'est bien passé
le proviseur est venu te voir non
rien du tout
il est passé devant moi il m'a même pas
regardé alors qu'il savait très bien que
j'étais devant lui
c'est incroyable il sait que tu étais
très proche de l'Insee il sait que tu as
harcelé
la moindre des choses c'est d'aller voir
de dire écoute il s'est passé un
drameurs
non plus qu'un professeur comme si de
rien n'était rien du tout
où il y a un problème excusez-moi je
suis désolé il se croyait pas un
professeur qui est venu te voir pour te
dire
c'est dramatique ce qui s'est passé on
soutient on va essayer que on va essayer
d'être auprès de toi non
juste ma prof d'anglais qui m'a demandé
comment j'allais si je tenais le coup
mais sinon les autres non
il y avait une derrière
les autres elles sont où
sur les quatre
il y en a une du coup bah je sais pas où
aller et les deux autres bah pour moi
elle se cache
ils vont plus à l'école ils ont pas de
parents ils sont en France
alors justement les parents garde les
parents parce que vous avez essayé de
contacter leurs parents
qui avait pas le dessus sur la fille
quoi c'est la gamine qui décidait et
même reçu des messages de la part d'une
des mamans les filles qui l'a harcelé il
lui dit ça va piquer je vais te démolir
dans tous les sens du terme collège des
pots de plainte et oui j'ai la vidéo on
voit été à grosse agresser Kenza et j'ai
la vidéo complète tout ce qui est légal
et qui détruira ta minable vie tu as
touché à la mauvaise personne et un deck
même si tu habites près du collège c'est
un accident c'est vite arrivé
ça c'est une maman ça alors d'accord qui
fait l'éducation normalement de ses
enfants mais là vous avez là vous avez
répondu là c'est la meilleure amie c'est
quoi ton problème
branle mer cousine vu ce que ta fille a
fait vous allez tous voir tu as fait
quoi quand l'histoire
elles ont essayé de se défendre ils ont
reçu du coca sur elle il y a une vidéo
qui a tourné donc elles ont essayé de se
défendre
qui a eu une bagarre et Miley Céline ont
été virés une journée d'accord c'est ça
parce que en fait si c'était passé quoi
au besoin elle continue à voir ce les
elles vous ont fait quoi elles vous ont
jeter du coca dessus et donc vous êtes
défendu et donc c'est pour ça que la
meilleure là vous vous menace c'est ça
et elle elles ont été une journée et
Cyril quand vous essayez de les
contacter les parents ils répondent non
on veut pas parler
on est en contact peut-être qu'on aura
un départ en
et le professeur n'a pas souhaité
s'exprimer sans doute un peu même pas de
recherche
une mutation libre
mais est-ce que ils nous ont envoyé à
l'Académie bien sûr ah oui mais
l'Académie
administrative
et ce qui est sidérant aussi c'est que
le ministre de l'Éducation monsieur
Papin Guy ne monte pas au créneau sur
cette responsabilité
sur les plateaux de télé
c'est qu'elle a l'air très seul est-ce
que tu fais partie d'un groupe de filles
toi aussi ou pas est-ce que vous êtes à
des copines qui t'entourent en ce moment
oui ça va
parce que tu as l'air assez seul je
trouve face à ce combat c'est horrible
de rentrer comme ça à l'école en fait
Maëlys a des copines et copains mais sa
meilleure amie était l'Insee quoi elle
faisait tout à deux
c'était souvent à la maison
comme Maëlys était souvent chez les
parents de l'Insee dès qu'on partait
dans un parc d'attraction ben elles
étaient ensemble elle faisait tout à
deux
provisoire il faut qu'il vienne
s'exprimer ok
[Musique]
on lâchera pas l'histoire il va demander
sa mutation mais ça c'est inadmissible
parce que aujourd'hui comment ça va se
passer pour toi Maëlys tu veux toujours
retourner dans ce collège tu étais
comment tu arrives à retourner dans ce
collège tu arrives à vivre où tu vis
actuellement c'est un traumatisme mais
non pour toi ah oui mais pour le collège
ça va pour l'instant
mais je pense que au fil du temps les
souvenirs bah vu que j'étais tout le
temps avec Lindsay les souvenirs vont
remonter et je pourrai plus aller moi je
comprends pas
on peut pas même il y a une enquête ils
vont quand même voir le proviseur et le
proviseur pour moi il a quand même une
réussite
pour le moment dans l'enquête judiciaire
il n'est pas concerné peut-être le
sera-t-il dans l'enquête administrative
le problème d'une enquête administrative
je suis désolé les mecs excusez-moi oui
il peut l'être il l'est pas pour le
moment le problème d'une enquête
administrative c'est que ça va durer des
mois ça va s'évaporer dans les limbes et
il y aura il y aura rien du tout qui va
se laisser ça et moi j'ai une question
aussi sur le fonctionnement actuel de
l'établissement parce que au départ il y
avait six jeunes qui ont été entendus
par la police cap qui ont été mis en
examen et moi en me suggère
éventuellement que les deux restantes
sont encore dans l'établissement et
peut-être sont encore en train de monter
voilà faut monter de nouvelles façons de
harceler en tout cas de mal se comporter
est-ce que c'est vrai ça est-ce qu'il y
a encore du groupe initial quelques
personnes qui sont en train de préparer
des mauvais coups à l'intérieur de
l'établissement Madame
on sait pas trop en fait je sais qu'il
va avoir un rebondissement parce que
mettre de Buisson
[Musique]
a eu des nouvelles preuves et donc qui
va avoir une conférence de presse jeudi
dans le village où l'Insee s'est suicidé
je dis à 11h il y aura une conférence de
presse nationale quoi et je pense que on
en saura un peu plus par rapport à ce
que maître de Buisson a pu découvrir
Maylis aujourd'hui
et la rendre fière surtout